comment ça va comment vous allez ça va
je pense bien pour vous aujourd'hui on
va parler d'un sujet extrêmement
important aujourd'hui à savoir pourquoi
il ne faut absolument pas que vous
dormiez à côté de votre smartphone et on
est très nombreux très nombreux à le
faire et c'est une très mauvaise idée
d'ailleurs doublement vous tout de suite
en commentaire mettait la pause et mark
et moi est ce que vous vous dormez à
côté de votre smartphone est ce que
c'est une pratique que vous faites est
ce que c'est quelque chose de courant
est ce que au contraire vos smartphones
il dort pas à côté de vous marquer moi
tout ça on bat mettez la pause marquée
le mois en bas en commentaire je suis
vraiment curieux de voir ce que vous
allez marquer au début de la vidéo
est-ce que vous pourrez éventuellement
marqué à la fin de la vidéo les imiter
la pause marquée le jeu bouge pas
j'attende du patient le temps comme ça
on en parle dans le micro
ok c'est bon ok on peut y aller la toute
première chose avant tout vous dire sur
ce sujet qui est vraiment extrêmement
passionnant est vraiment très
intéressant et bien je vous invite à
vous abonner pourquoi parceque vous
présente beaucoup de nouveaux produits
jon klein d'astuces dans l'utilisation
de vos produits smartphones et compagnie
on parle également de mon métier
d'ordinateur on parle de plein de choses
donc si c'est pas déjà le cas si vous
n'êtes pas abonné si vous voulez tout
savoir
par rapport aux nouvelles technologies
par rapport à vos usages et par rapport
à votre vie numérique d'une façon un peu
globale et bien cliquer en bas soit
bouton rouge vous vous abonnez vous
activer la cloche et ce sera merveilleux
c'est dangereux de dormir à côté de son
téléphone il ya plusieurs risques je
vais tous vous voulez développer vous
expliquez vous le détailler
j'ai mon ordi sous les yeux j'ai pris
toutes mes notes
elles sont juste là et on va regarder ça
ensemble moi je suis un très gros
utilisateurs de smartphones voyez j'en
ai fait mon métier puisque je vous en
parle tout le temps sur youtube
j'ai toujours cette petite bête l'âme à
côté de moi j'ai toujours à côté de mon
lit et un jour j'ai eu un déclic une
prise de conscience et je vous en
parlais plus tard dans le podcast en me
disant ok il ya un problème il ya un
vrai problème
autant ces machines là sont vraiment
génial parce que elle vous apporte plein
d'usagé elle vous solutionne plein de
problèmes et elle vous permet de faire
plein de choses qu'on pouvait pas faire
avant et ça c'est vraiment génial par
contre elles apportent aussi leur lot de
déconvenues et les problèmes qui vont
avec
il ya huit personnes sur dix qui
garderaient leur smartphone à lui mais à
côté d'eux sur le chevet sur le sol
enfants tout cas à une distance de moins
d'un mètre la nuit il ya 60% des
français là je parle que des français a
donc imagine que vous en tout cas si
vous n'êtes pas en france et bien sûr ça
doit être sensiblement la même chose
pour nous d'ailleurs le jeu contre nous
pour mieux marquer un banc commentaires
il ya 60% des français qui dès qu'ils
ouvrent
mieux un des premiers gestes qu'ils font
est bien c'est de consulter leurs
smartphones et 1 9 français sur 10 qui
lorsqu'ils sont coucher le soir
consultent leurs smartphones et regarde
bien ce soit les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit à leurs e-mails que ce soit les
actualités qui regarde une série un film
en tout cas on est très nombreux à avoir
ces usages la ses usages là sont nocifs
sont assez mauvais et je me suis dit
tiens pourquoi pas en parler en vidéo
dire qu'est ce qui va mal aussi avec le
smartphone je vous parle beaucoup des
nouvelles technologies je suis un très
grand amoureux des mots la technologie
les apporte plein de chose de positif
mais aussi pas mal de choses négatives
et c'est important de pouvoir le dire
qu'on est tous des usages adapté à notre
vie de tous les jours et qu'on se laisse
pas non plus dévoré par une petite
machine
alors pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce
que la nuit et je pense que là je vous
apprendrai rien c'est le moment où on
recharge nos batteries enfin peu comme
le smartphone lorsque vous le branchez
on se prépare pour une nouvelle
utilisation pour une nouvelle journée et
on a besoin de bien se reposer dans les
meilleures conditions la première
question je me suis posée c'est pourquoi
est-ce que je dors à côté de mon
smartphone la première raison qui m'est
venue tout de suite en tête at elle un
peu pour justifier le truc c'est le
réveil
eh bien oui le gipa de radio réveil dans
ma chambre je me dis tiens je le prends
jamais l'application réveille et je me
réveille tous les matins avec la sortie
de mon smartphone c'est extrêmement
pratique bien il ya des applications
dédiées nativement dans votre smartphone
ok c'est un truc qui marche c'est le
premier point le deuxième point je me
suis souvent dit si quelqu'un m'appelle
s'il ya une urgence si un problème
et bien je louperai je ne pourrais pas
aider la personne mes proches en tout
cas il ya un côté un peu culpabilisateur
couche de pendant très longtemps à côté
de moi pour pouvoir répondre en cas d'un
besoin urgent et pressants et puis
troisième point est ce qu'il faut le
reconnaître on est accro à ces machines
là on est réellement accroc et on a
beaucoup de mal à décrocher
et ça ça fera l'objet du podcast dont je
vous parlerai très très prochainement
parce que où il faut le reconnaître on a
des addictions à nos smartphones qu'est
ce que va provoquer la diction
d'elle-même avant même de parler des
effets sur notre corps on va avoir des
difficultés d'endormissement parce qu'on
passe beaucoup de temps le soir avec une
lumière qui n'est pas naturel en plein
dans nos yeux directement alors que
souvent tout le reste de l'éclairage est
coupée à la maison pour certaines
personnes ce qui n'est pas mon cas mais
je sais que pour certaines personnes
et bien c'est le fait de se réveiller la
nuit de prendre aux smartphones et de
regarder si on n'a pas une notification
ou un message important et on consulte
nos messages en pleine nuit et après
pour vous rendre bien évidemment c'est
absolument la galère parce que qu'est ce
que fait votre smartphone lorsque vous
l'utilisez le soir avant de vous coucher
ou si vous utilisez en pleine nuit
eh bien ça va venir stimuler votre
cerveau et ça vous garder en éveil
beaucoup
plus longtemps il ya une étude qui dit
que le fait d'utiliser son smartphone
avant de se coucher ça diminuerait de 30
à 45 minutes la durée du sommeil et ça
vient interférer avec ce qu'on appelle
le cycle circadien notamment le fait de
pouvoir vous endormir puisque le fait
d'avoir cette lumière dans les yeux ça
inhibe ray la production de mélatonine
la mélatonine c'est l'hormone du sommeil
qui va faire que vous allez vous sentir
voir les paupières lourdes fatigué bayel
soi et bien force de bombarder vos yeux
que la lumière des smartphones est bien
la mélatonine
elle tarde à venir et vous endormez
forcément plus tard ça c'est le premier
point qui est vraiment liés à
l'addiction aux smartphones
on en a besoin on le regarde on n'arrive
pas à décrocher ça nous procure une
sensation de bien-être immédiat grâce à
la libération de la dopamine
ça va bien plus loin que ça puisque
dormir à côté pour smartphones
augmenterez l'anxiété un point que j'ai
remarqué chez moi en tout cas le fait de
dire je dois garder mon smartphone à
côté de moi
si on a besoin de moi ça veut dire que
ce soit dans un état d'hypervigilance je
prête l'oreille déquilibre je le prends
à ce qui est quelque chose d'important
ça joue aussi sur la culpabilité sur le
fait de devoir être là pour répondre aux
autres et qu'on s'en rende compte
ou pas d'un point de vue purement
inconscient ça vous gène her2 l'anxiété
on les salue mais à côté de soi au cas
où l'on sait jamais on pourrait en avoir
besoin et on se culpabiliser en se
disant que s'il se passe quelque chose
et qu'on l'avait éteint on s'en voudra
parce que je vous conseille pour pallier
à ça et si vous avez vraiment des
besoins ou dans votre famille vos amis
des choses qui pourrait s'avérer urgente
est vraiment importante eh bien vous
reprenez la bonne vieille ligne fixe de
téléphone peut-être n'avez-vous une chez
vous ou alors vous pouvez raccordés sur
votre box sa solutionnera ce problème et
ça vous évitera de dire vous irradié la
nuit là je vous parle de côté qui sont
liées plus à notre psyché mais on va se
parler des ondes puisque c'est l'un des
problèmes majeurs puisque oui vous le
savez je vous apprendrai rien pour
pouvoir communiquer avec l'extérieur vos
smartphones et met et reçoivent des
ondes en permanence vous avez donc les
hommes qui vont se connecter aux réseaux
cellulaires mais vous avez également les
ondes de votre wii fit autant dire que
les ondes vous en avez tous les côtés
avec ça et vous êtes bombardé donc
imaginez si vous dormez entre six sept
ou huit heures par nuit vous avez votre
smartphone qui est posé sur votre chevet
qui a moins de 1 mètre de vous et qui
émet des ondes dans toutes les
directions les bepa raison dans une
direction très précise
non il rayonne vraiment à 360 degrés
autant dire que vous vous êtes là et
votre corps absorbe les ondes même si
aujourd'hui effectivement eu des études
il qu'on n'a pas de recul donc
dangerosité immédiate par rapport aux
hommes parce que le smartphone existe
depuis à peine 13 ans même s'il y avait
des téléphones portables avant c'est
quelque chose qui a allait tout casser
sur le grand public 20 ans et encore 20
ans est extrêmement large
donc on n'a pas beaucoup de recul à
moyen et long termes sur les effets
délétères que peuvent avoir le
smartphone alors imaginez vous les
autorités déjà vous conseille d'utiliser
un kit mains libres on ne sait jamais
principe de précaution posez votre
smartphone à côté de votre tête à moins
de 1 mètre pendant 6 7 heures non-stop
sans compter de ce que vous allez faire
la journée on le pose aux côtés de vous
sur votre bureau
et bien c'est néfaste d'une manière
générale il faut laisser son corps
récupérés le laisser se reposer la nuit
donc loin de ça lorsqu'il est activé
d'autant plus que le fait d'avoir son
smartphone à côté de sa tête ça nuit à
la qualité de votre sommeil
déjà vous avez du mal à vous endormir et
lorsque vous dormez en plus vous dormez
vous dormez mal le pire qu'à sept points
de vos smartphones de poser votre
oreille et de dormir directement dessus
parce que lorsqu'il est en mode vibreur
comme ça vous ne louperez aucun message
aucun appel et je vous dis ça parce que
ça arrive laurier ne filtrent pas les
ont donc très clairement bon vous l'avez
une distance extrêmement proche de votre
tête pendant désolant alors vous dormez
ja c'est relativement mauvais pour votre
cerveau par très très très mauvais et en
plus de ça vous risquez de faire
chauffer le smartphone il ya plein de
risques qui sont liées à ça c'est très
dangereux ne fait pas ne le fait jamais
à proscrire vous oubliez d'ailleurs dit
moi si ça vous est déjà arrivé en bas en
commentaire là on vous il ya plein de
problèmes mon smartphone ça va pas
dormir à côté peut pas être vers moi pas
utiliser si je regarde le soir joueurs
du mal à m'endormir ok c'est très
anxiogène tout ça c'est très anxieuse et
de ça mais rassurez vous il ya plein de
solutions il ya plein de bonnes
solutions la toute première c'est si
vous voulez vraiment le regarder le soir
et regarder des actualités chose comme
ça ce que vous faites c'est que vous
activez le mode nocturne
ça évitera les effets néfastes quant à
la production de mélatonine alors c'est
pas idéal mais c'est toujours je dirais
la moindre mal et lorsque vous avez
terminé le mieux c'est de l'état si vous
ne pouvez pas létales parce que vous
avez un réveil et que votre smartphone
ne se rallument pas lorsque vous avez un
réveil de programmer ça arrive chez
certains et pas tous à ce moment là vous
mettez au moins le mode avion ce qui
fait qu'il ne communiquera pas avec le
wifi il ne cherchera pas de réseau et au
moins il n'émettra pas nombre maintenant
si vous devez absolument le garder
allumée à côté de vous pour recevoir un
appel qui serait extrêmement important
et bien de regarder par un maître de
vous
aidez le à plus de 1 m mettez le
beaucoup plus loin pourquoi pas avec une
petite sonnerie toute douce sylla lui
mais quand vous dormez plus les loin et
mieux ce sera mettez le dans une autre
pièce vous pouvez couper le wifi puisque
vous n'allez pas l'utiliser et puis si
c'est juste la question du réveil qui
vous bloque acheter un bon vieux réveil
vous le programme et vous le posez à
côté de vous il aimait pas de monde
c'est ça il sait bien et en plus ça fera
travailler le commerce comme ça c'est
magnifique et essayer de décrocher
passer moins de temps le sport sur votre
smartphone accordez-vous du temps pour
vous du temps de qualité
le fait d'être sur les réseaux sociaux
le soir le fait de regarder un email n'y
a rien de pire vous tomber sur un os
nommé professionnel ça y est c'est la
mort ça vous tue votre nuit
et bien c'est mauvais vous le prenez
vous le posez séparez vous ont au moins
une bonne heure avant d'aller vous
coucher prenez-vous un bon vieux bouquin
renouer avec le bouquin n'avait pas
mirambeau cas là dessus parce que vous
allez récupérer tous les effets néfastes
il la solution idéale pour moi c'est vos
smartphones quand vous décidez d'aller
vous coucher vous le prenez vous
l'éteignez vous le posez loin vous avez
votre bon vieux réveil à côté vous vous
lisez un bon bouquin ou rendormez vous
êtes tranquille et là vous allez avoir
un vrai bon sommeil récupérateur et vous
n'allez pas vous griller le cerveau
pendant la nuit
et pour aller plus loin je dirais même
que le mieux c'est carrément de couper
le wifi de votre maison puisque oui vous
n'avez pas l'utiliser la nuit vous
pouvez programmer depuis votre box
certains routeurs également qui vous
permet de le programmer ça ne sert à
rien que vous ayez des ondes dans votre
appartement puisque vous n'allez pas
l'utiliser de la même manière sortaient
tous les appareils électroniques de
votre chambre
faites vous un vrai sas de décompression
avant d'aller vous coucher smartphone
extérieur smartwatch extérieur pas de
télé rien on se pose on se recentre sur
soi on se fait du bien et on est prêt à
se détendre à se relâcher et aller au
dodo
cette vidéo n'est pas une tribune contre
les smartphones j'adore les smartphones
ce que vous pouvez faire avec c'est
incroyable ça vous apporte de vraies
belles solutions quotidienne mais il
faut aussi avoir conscience des dangers
des smartphones de nos usages qui ne
sont pas toujours les bons et il ya
derrière des vraies questions santé
publique c'est un sujet effectivement
sérieux ça peut paraître un peu
anxiogène je pense que c'est des bonnes
pratiques qu'on doit mettre en place
nous au quotidien pour notre santé puis
surtout se déculpabiliser et vraiment se
faire son auto critique par rapport à
son usage savoir ce qui va et ce qui ne
va pas maintenant vous avez regardé
cette vidéo dites moi vous ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire est ce
que dans les points que j'ai cité l'état
dans lequel vous vous reconnaissez sur
les usages d'utilisation avant d'aller
vous coucher sur le fait de leurs gardes
et la nuit sur le fait de ne jamais les
timbres soit fait de laisser les ombres
partout et en permanence
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
et en commentaire quant à nous on se
retrouve dès demain pour continuer à
parler texte fait les goûts
gros bisous j'aurai beaucoup d'amour
[Musique]